[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه
الوصول القمه مش سهل في حكايتنا النهارده
عن عشر سنين في تاريخ محمد علي وازاي بقى
محمد علي ده اللي بيحكي عنه فيلم عليه
اهلا بك في حلقه جديده
في الوقت ده صاني
بمجرد ما تلاقي بيقدر يشوف بوضوح بينزل
الحلبه وبيسيطر على النزال مره ثانيه وفي
الجوله السابعه بيستسلم بلاستيم وبعدها
بيبقى كلاي ثاني اصغر بطل للوزن الثقيل
بعد فلويد باترسون
[موسيقى]
كانوا اصحاب جدا وبيقضوا وقت كبير سوا
وبعد فوز بلاي بالبطوله بيتم دعوته المنزل
زعيم امه الاسلام ايليا محمد وهنا بيتلقوا
عليه اسم محمد علي تغيير اسم كاسيس بلاي
لمحمد علي خلى ولد تلاقيه متعصب ورفض ده
تماما بس تلاقي حافظ على اسم محمد
نفسها واسلوبها وتعاملها الغير متوافق مع
تعليم الاسلام وفي الوقت ده محمد علي
هيرفض يروح مع ملك الرحله اللي اتفقوا
عليها بيتم اغتيال وده سبب له صدمه نفسيه
بعدها على طول بيتم استدعاء محمد علي
للتجنيد ولكنه بيرفض التجنيد الاجباري
وبسبب ده بيتسحب منه رخصه الملاكمه وجواز
السفر واللقب واتحكم عليه بالسجن لمده خمس
سنين عليه
[موسيقى]
لمده ثلاث سنين بتلغي ادانته وهيرجع
للحلبه ثاني وهيواجه جيري وفاز بالضربه
القاضيه في الدوله رقم ثلاثه بيحاول محمد
علي استعاده بطوله الوزن الثقيل ضد
جوفريزر في معركه القرن بس فريزر كان ليه
اليد العليا ضد علي وبيفوز هو بالبطوله
ودي تعتبر الخساره الاولى
بيتم تحديد مباراه ما بين علي وفورمان في
زئير اسمها معركه الغابه خلال وجود علي في
زهير هيكتشف الاضطهاد اللي بيتعرض له هناك
وبيصر علي ان البطوله تقام في زئير لانه
كان رافض السياسه اللي تم هناك وفي الوقت
ده بيتعرف على برونيكا بورشيه وبيعجب بها
جدا وبتنتشر اشاعات في الصحف عن معرفتهم
ببعض بعدها بتسافر زوجته
وبتساله انت بتحبها بيقول انا مش عارف انا
كنت بحب فرانك ولا لا بس كل اللي بيهمني
دلوقتي
فيلم علي هو فيلم درامي رياضي امريكي عن
السيره الذاتيه لمحمد علي كلاي نزل سنه
2001 مشارك في كتابته وانتاجه واخراجه
مايكل مان الفيلم بيركز على عشر سنين من
حياه الملاكم محمد علي من سنه 1964 لسنه
1974 قدم شخصيه محمد علي الممثل ولسماس
وعلى الرغم ان الفيلم نزل في 2001 بس
الشغل عليه بدا في 1992 لما قدر المنتج هو
ار جي باخذ حقوق فيلم لقصه محمد علي كلاي
وفي سنه 1992 زار محمد علي في عيد ميلاده
ال 50 واقنعه بالسماح له انه يعمل فيلم عن
حياته وفي برايس سنه
بدات تصوير فلوس انجلس في 11 يناير سنه
2001 بميزانيه قدرها 150 مليون دولار وتم
التصوير في مدينه نيويورك
لما الفيلم نزل تلقى ويل سميث
الاوسكار لافضل ممثلين الفيلم ازهر شخصيه
محمد عليه بالشخص السيد الصنع وبالذات مع
السيدات اتجوز مرتين جوازات ما كملتش كثير
وخسر زواجه الاخير بسبب معرفته بواحده
ثانيه بس الكل بطل مميزات وعيوب محمد علي
القى ضوعه على حرب فيتنام وكان بيدافع عن
قضيهم محمد علي شخصيه متمرده جدا ما تقدرش
تهزه عن قراره واثق في اللي بيعمله وبينفذ
اللي بيقولوا محمد علي بيقول
دايلر كبير
[موسيقى]
وده كان كنايه عن مدى سرعه حركه محمد علي
جوهر وبالفعل هو كان قوي وسريع جدا وبيقدر
يهزم اخصامه وما خسرش في مسيرته كلها غير
مره واحده بس فيلم محمد علي من الافلام
اللي كلها صراعات صراع ما بين السود
والبيض ما بين الحكومات وزراعه على السلطه
فيلم هياخذك في رحله لمده 10 سنين في حياه
واحد من اشهر ابطال الملاكمه في العالم
شوف الفيلم دلوقتي وشاركني رايك فيه على
السوشيال ميديا واستناني الحلقه اللي جايه
افلام المقدم بالعربي
[موسيقى]